hello and welcome to 0 plane the
Chessmaster 6 640 probably or 64 you
never know 64 oh you never know that
even rhymes yeah i think my results with
this line are pretty good oh it
struggled and find something good
against you for maybe this is something
that I should study I mean I playing
this without knowing anything so my
somewhat decent results they might point
towards this being an opening line that
I could investigate further them hmm i
don't like this so much energy for a
foster home not happy about this so
coming with g 4 and so on but ok i have
94 was g5 a problem hmm maybe g5 is a
problem cakes bishop cheeks I'm in a
pretty awful pin potentially with 95 I
go snipe defy the me at lame uh-huh
okay it's a surprising move ok so let's
take it and wait wait wait wait I don't
have to go to 7am yet I can also go back
but it looks looks weird going back
looks weird here f I have five is a
weird move again ok let's keep this
covered
okay trying to put the night on h4 he
really doesn't doesn't seem to believe
that this is in any way dangerous so I
can yeah this is the thing I can allow
him to take b6 on but why not why not
hmm ok I like this i want to play anyway
so let's do that
I could have played Bishop a seven just
keeping this piece but it's not quite
clear what the bishop is doing you can
argue that it still does more than the
night on a four just like completely
useless but ok I didn't want to play and
necessarily complicated stuff this looks
a good enough ok five
okay there's no tactical we're here to
punish this right don't think so i can't
have to go back round okay um Creech you
have 61 move Queen to g5 a couple of
things may be here boy I've also have 96
sometimes yeah we'll see see what it
does now ya f for the shirt back no
I don't know about f4 here it's not
threatening much and I can premiere we
can just double him I just double if I
get and get a double play okay now it
takes that what that's possible but
check gyuki to is made right check where
isn't that checkmate I rook c8 is
drawing all jack whoa check stupid I
should have thought about this a little
bit yeah at least take a pawn first and
stuff damn it okay can I have VoIP the
drawer somehow maybe with cheese some g6
rookie 725 and I really don't want to
draw here that's its kind of really
awful check probably is a draw and tingo
g5 as well trip to chik chik there check
check time morning yeah I what a bloody
shame read the three don't like to draw
this game but I don't don't see how I
can continue especially considering the
time
check okay I have to check check check
check check game run what a damn shame
it's it's just just crazy check check
check o king of six oh my god I can go
here check check chicks here I'm going
then ok check tease out of checks and
I'm winning oh how stupid is that I mean
this is totally suicidal check
completely suicidal what what is doing I
just don't take this gift check Chanti
it's really a draw there was kind of
interesting position but taking on a
choice really really amazing yeah then I
don't checkmate him oh my god ah the
king yeah interesting opening him I
thought I thought g5 was interesting you
try to prepare this I wasn't quite sure
what to respond to that I think why does
a bit bad him the engine wants to play
this ultimately but this doesn't look
good and I was a good opportunity on
here I'm certainly ok now with the night
coming down here blackest is very very
ok
then yeah yeah I wanted to give me the
point I didn't take it oh my thanks for
watching